-Our first guest tonight is a
Golden Globe-nominated actress
you know from shows
like "Parks and Recreation,"
as well as the films
"The Little Hours"
and "Ingrid Goes West."
She stars in and produced
"Emily the Criminal,"
which is
streaming now on Netflix.
She also, just this morning,
received
a Golden Globe nomination
for "The White Lotus,"
which you can catch on HBO Max.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Aubrey Plaza,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Aubrey, I'm so happy
you're here!
-I'm happy, too.
-I was always so thrilled
that we were getting you,
you know,
the night after the
season finale of "White Lotus,"
but then the added bonus --
you got your Golden Globe
nomination today.
Congratulations.
-I know. What the -- What?
-I know.
-What? Why?
-Were you excited?
Was it an exciting thing
to find out?
-Yeah.
I was completely blown away.
I mean --
-That's great.
-I couldn't believe it.
-It's so well deserved.
I reached out to you
midway through the season
because it's so wonderful
to see you in this part.
It's so great.
And it must have been so --
And I should note,
we are gonna spoil the show.
-Yes.
-But everybody should
have watched it when it aired.
You spoiled it for us
by not watching it.
[ Laughter ]
Did you love
that you knew this thing
that everybody was so desperate
to find out?
-Um, yeah.
I love having
knowledge and secrets
to hold over everyone.
-You're good with
knowledge and secrets.
-Yeah. Yeah, it's fun.
It's fun.
I was actually surprised
by how many people
didn't want to know.
It's kind of a litmus test
for people.
It's, like, certain people
want to know,
and it really tells a lot
about a person
that wants the spoiler
and doesn't care.
-It's true.
-Right?
-One of the great things
about the show is
there is
this element of mystery.
Obviously, you know
from the first shot
that someone or some people die.
-Uh-huh.
-But the show
is so fun to watch
that even if it wasn't
this mystery,
you would love the time
you spent with the characters.
So it's not necessarily
the most important thing.
But when you told people,
were they happy?
Like, when you spoiled it
for people ahead of time,
did you feel joy in their eyes?
-[ Laughs ]
-No. I mean, I don't know.
Like, some people --
People are shady.
Some people --
I got some texts
about some Vegas betting.
-Oh, really?
-Some people -- Yeah.
-Some people wanted to
get inside info
and then go place big money?
-Yeah, yeah,
there was, like,
insider trading happening.
I try to not get involved
in anything illegal.
You know?
But, yeah, I don't know.
Some people --
Yeah, most people don't --
don't want to know.
But some people
are just like, "Tell me.
I don't care."
I'm like, "You're sick."
[ Laughter ] =
And I'll be like,
"She kills all the gays
and then kills herself
by accident.
Ha! Bye.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
Like, that's what happened,
right?
-Yeah, Yeah,
that's what happened.
-Yeah, it's weird.
I don't know,
it really tells a lot
about a person.
-Was there a character
you wish had died?
[ Laughter ]
You don't have to say
if you don't want to.
-I mean, Cameron.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people are speculating
because, again,
we don't ever see what happens
with Harper and Cameron
in the bedroom.
We only hear your side of it.
What do you think
actually happened?
You, as an actor,
how did you approach it?
-As an actor?
-Like, as you played
the character...
-Uh-huh?
-...and the...
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-[ Laughs ]
-What do you think happens?
I haven't seen the final --
I haven't seen the edited --
-I believe, Harper.
I believe that they --
-What did I say?
-That they kissed.
-That's what I said?
-Yeah.
-That we kissed?
-That's what your character
said, yeah.
-And what else?
-The way you're looking at me,
like --
-I told you, Seth,
I haven't seen it.
I don't know what goes on --
-You were there.
Stop acting like
I have an experience
that's unique from yours.
I swear to God, it was you.
I watched you.
[ Laughter ]
-I know what happened, okay?
And what happened is,
we did some stuff.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And I hated every minute of it.
-Okay. Good.
-It was disgusting.
[ Laughter ]
And there was no penetration.
-Oh, wow.
-I don't know!
-This is very exciting.
-Why?
What do you think happened?
-Like I said, I believed Harper
that it was just a kiss.
I mean, again, this is --
I mean, I'm trusting you as --
-Just a kiss?
-Yeah.
You're making me feel
like a dope now
that I believe your performance.
-No, I just didn't know
how it was --
-I mean, I think maybe --
I think maybe each of you
grabbed the other one's butt.
[ Laughter ]
Through clothes.
-I think I grabbed
a little more than that.
[ Laughter ]
What does my husband do?
That's the real question.
-What does your husband --
-Yeah, what does he do
with, you know, what's-her-face?
-Oh, when they, like,
sort of stroll off?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. All of a sudden, you're
like, "I haven't seen it,"
but you know a lot about it.
-I read the scripts.
[ Laughter ]
-At the end, we see --
-How did they put together?
-Well, now I feel weird
telling you
about the show you're in.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not -- First of all,
I'm gonna watch it all.
But I want to watch --
I've seen one and two.
I want to watch them all, like,
with a very --
with, like,
a magnum bottle of wine.
-Yeah, that's
a good way to watch it.
-And then I just want to
watch them all
like a movie because, for me,
it's like a seven-hour movie.
And it hurts too much.
It's too -- It's like I --
It's such a slow burn,
I couldn't handle it.
-You mean, when you watched
the first two?
-When I tried to watch the --
Yeah.
I was like, "I can't do this.
I got to do it in one sitting."
So I'm waiting to do that.
-Now, you do know, at the end,
there's sort of a shot of you --
-What?
-Harper and Ethan
are at the airport.
-Doing what?
-And they just kind of
look like
they're gonna be okay.
Do you think long-term
they're gonna be okay?
-[ Sighs ]
I mean, I'll just say
that I was really gunning for
doing some takes
where, like,
maybe we weren't so happy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I -- I don't know.
Maybe they'll be okay.
But I have a kind of fantasy
that Harper divorces him
and takes all his money.
-Okay, that's a good fantasy.
And we don't know.
We're all allowed to have
our own fantasies
about these characters.
-Yeah, I have
a lot of fantasies.
[ Laughter ]
-I have one last thing
to ask you about.
-What?
-Your costar Meghann was here.
-Yes.
-She told a story
about you guys going on a hike
in Sicily,
and she took responsibility
for the fact
that you got lost on this hike.
She said she'd done this hike
a bunch on her own,
and the one time
she brought you, she got lost.
But you feel like
she left out a detail.
-Okay, first of all,
Meghann Fahy is
an incredible actress.
-She's so wonderful.
-I just want to
give it up to her.
Her performance on the show
is sick.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-In the finale, as well.
She has a moment in the finale
which is really tremendous.
-She slays, even though, like,
character-wise, I'm like,
"You're trying to
[Bleep] my husband?
Uh, no."
[ Laughter ]
But that's my -- No, she --
Yeah, I saw her on your show
because I watch your show.
And she left out
the most important part,
which is that we
were on mushrooms.
So first of all...
[ Laughter ]
And I don't know if, like,
maybe her parents don't like --
-Her parents were actually here
that night.
-Oh, no. Sorry, Meghann.
-They left with her.
Don't worry.
-We took a little one.
-Okay.
-And so,
when she was telling the
story -- because I watched it.
I'm like, she told the story,
and it was like,
"Aubrey was on the road,
and all these Italian guys
are on motorcycles,
and Aubrey was like,
'Don't look at me.'"
I was tripping.
It was terrifying.
[ Laughter ]
We were lost on a highway,
and there were Italian men going
"Vroom, vroom,"
like, coming at me.
I was like --
I thought they were taking me
to the dark side.
Like, I was gonna transfer over.
-She told a story
that made you seem
rude to Italian motorists.
-I was tripping balls, bitch.
[ Laughter ]
-She left out
some massive context.
-I know.
-Well...
-Mushrooms are really good
for depression, though.
-Oh, that's good, until
you end up on the highway.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, I also want to ask you
about "Emily the Criminal,"
which is a fantastic film
that you are starring in
and produced.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be back with more
from Aubrey Plaza.